I'm on vacation right now,
so I haven't been able to access and read
the entire New York Times article
about the ballerina farms tribe wife phenomenon,
but I have seen some clips and some takeaways,
so let's talk about it. This entire time,
I think all of us assumed that she had full time nanny help
and potentially overnight nanny help.
The fact that she says she doesn't,
that there is no outside help other than a homeschool teacher,
is almost more shocking and more upsetting somehow,
because it means that she actually is not getting a break.
It means. And once again,
this is the problem with glamorizing this sort of Chad wife lifestyle.
It leads to this sort of subservient self sacrifice
that is unsustainable.
Another creator quoted the article and said that Daniel,
the husband,
made light of the fact that she gets so overwhelmed sometimes
with how much she does that she has to stay in bed for a week.
That is clinical depression and or clinical exhaustion.
That's not something to be, like,
benchmarking as some sort of standard to hit.
There's this underlying religious tone of self sacrifice
on the part of the mother specifically.
That is a beast that will never be full and finished.
Because what's the standard for success?
What does it look like to be a successful child life?
Is it working yourself to death?
Is it so your husband can look at you like a prize workhorse in a Way.
I almost feel bad for this woman. Um,
and I didn't think I would say that.
Not because I don't understand her lifestyle, um,
but it because of how glamorize she's made it online
and those messages that are getting out to other people.
I don't know. She's drink the Kool aid, too,
and it's really fucking sad.
I will be back with more, like,
well articulated thoughts,
but that was just my first take
on hearing some of the things from this article.
I need to get, like,
somehow I have to be able to read it while I'm over here
so I can give a proper take.